-It is Tuesday, guys. It is time
for "WeTweet." Here we go.
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show
you five different tweets,
and we're all going to
vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have your
voting clickers at your seats.
I can tell right there
by the confusion.
There you go.
Like, "No, that's your clicker."
You can all vote for --
You can vote for all of them
if you want to.
You can vote for none of them.
I just want to you to have fun.
And then we're going to see
the results live.
Higgins, Roots, you all
have your clickers, as well?
-Ready, clicking away.
-Good.
Roots, nice to see you.
Whichever tweet
gets the most likes,
I will tweet it out live
on the show
during the commercial break,
and then you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a shared experience.
Alright, you guys ready?
Here we go.
The first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
When it's not you, yeah.
Alright.
Cast your vote,
thumbs up, thumbs down.
The votes are in. Let's go.
Let's just see
the results right here.
-Whoa!
-Whoa, not bad!
157.
-Wow.
-I feel good about that one.
-157 -- that's good.
-Very positive group
here tonight.
I like these guys.
The next one is...
♪♪
Sit, sit.
Sit.
Sit. Good boy.
Sit. Alright.
-I'm going to say not as good.
-I'm going to say
not as good on this one.
-Yeah.
-I like it, but I don't think --
-It's a valid point.
-Yeah, if we were playing
a different game.
-Yeah, I mean, a different game,
it'd be like --
-Valid Point.
That is a valid point.
-Dogs should exercise, yeah.
-That's correct.
-But this is a different game.
-Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, my God.
-Yeah. Wow!
-Wow.
-Knockout punch.
-Very honest audience.
Yeah, very honest.
They were giving
and then they --
They giveth
and they taketh away, yeah.
Alright, let's look at
this next one. It says...
That was a mistake.
Exhausted.
-Yeah.
-He's a great actor.
-Wow!
-One of the greatest actors
of all time.
Legendary actor.
-But you don't want your baby --
-No, no, no.
You don't want --
tired Gene Hackman.
Let's see the results
on this one here.
[ Drumroll ]
Alright, okay. Not bad.
-Wow.
-I love that the audience
is that honest.
They really are like, "Yeah,
I'm not going
to give it to you.
No."
You think it'd all be
200, 200-0.
No, the people are making
a choice here.
-Yeah.
They love Gene Hackman.
Next up, have this one.
♪♪
"It can go up --
It can go 150 feet above --
It can go 60 miles
on one charge.
You can --"
Like, "Yeah, yeah. Who cares?"
Let's see the results
on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh! That's shocking.
-Airport still --
-Airport still by five.
-Yeah. Because when you see
people running through, it's --
-I know.
-And sometimes,
the one wheel comes off,
and then you got to re--
You got to try to
figure out both wheels.
The one wheel goes off,
the Rollerblade wheel,
and then it's like, "Aah!"
Then it's turning, and then
you -- Yeah, you're in trouble.
Alright, this last one.
Yeah, I think that one's going
to be the winner, I think.
-You think airport or this one?
-I see this one here,
and I'm gonna say airport.
-Okay.
They all can't be winners, man.
-Yeah, I know, man.
-They all cannot be winners.
-Here we go.
It's a fun game either way.
-Yeah.
-Here's the last one here.
It says...
♪♪
-It's something --
-Some knew it, but --
-My kids would love that one.
-Your kids would dig that one.
-That's a valid point. Yeah.
-No, no,
we're not playing Valid Point.
-Oh, I thought we were
playing Valid Point.
-That is not the game
we're playing.
We're not playing Valid Point.
-That "sit," and this one --
-No, no, it's not Valid Point.
"Dinnerables" --
it's got to beat 157.
I think not,
but let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, there we go right there!
I like it.
I'm happy with "airport."
Thank you all very much.
The winner is number one,
"airport," right there.
Seeing someone else run
is fun as hell.
I'm going post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like, give it a
"WeTweet," and enjoy.